[Music]
foreign
good morning the father of Ellie Edwards
who was shot and killed on Christmas Eve
near Liverpool has described the pain
that her death has caused speaking to
Sky News Tim Edwards said his daughter
was beautiful and caring and had a heart
of gold
22 year old Connor Chapman will face
trial later this year accused of murder
Sky correspondent imziban Rasheed
reports from the world
it's just a fantastic human being
beautiful
hearts are gold
for those who loved her there will never
be enough words to describe Ellie
Edwards
for the first time since she was shot
dead on Christmas Eve her Father Tim
Found the courage and strength to share
some she's the type of person that you
would she would walk in a room
and
their normal gravitate towards her
because she was so smile and she
beautiful looking she was
to use a hugger
but at the age of just 26 this
beautician's life was cut brutally short
her family left inconsolable
she's still the glue
she still keeps us together
uh
and that will always be the case
thank you
never change
at what was meant to be a time of
Celebration Tim's family were faced with
utter tragedy
for it to happen on Christmas Eve
how
how disturbing was that as a family it
was not real
the important layer
and of course Christmas will never be
the same never
her killing marked the fifth fatal
shooting in merseyside since August last
year an innocent life lost with
remarkable consequences
there's no winners with gun club there's
nowhere
you pick up but now if your Future's
over
and everybody else's future around you
is over
Tim says Ellie can't be forgotten and
it's likely she won't especially amongst
the hundreds expected to attend her
funeral next week
it's going to be tolerable isn't it it's
not going to be nice that's not going to
be good
it was part of the process and that's
just something that has to be done
She'll always be here
she'll never believe me
yeah she'll live on forever
into my Rasheed Sky News the Wirral
it's a breaking news for you now and the
latest monthly retail sales figures have
just been released and they show a fall
of one percent in December so let's get
the latest on this uh our business
correspondent Paul Kelso joins me now a
support one percent fall in retail sales
in December more disappointment for the
High Street
indeed and that's a monthly fall so
that's one percent down on the figure
for November uh and um it's still almost
two percent below covid uh levels of
spending in December year on year of
course we're comparing it's December
just past with 2021 when Omicron uh cut
football on the High Street dramatically
so these figures will be a
disappointment to retailers and they
come say this is the office for National
statistics uh figures and they say there
is feedback from retailers and wider
evidence that consumers are cutting back
because of increased prices and the
challenge of affordability uh perhaps no
surprise we've had a slew of economic
data this week it's uh the week and the
month when the ons put out a range of
figures we've seen inflation still above
10 that of course has been feeding
through into prices all year we've seen
a perhaps uh a little tightening in the
uh challenge in the labor market
increasing employment unemployment
Rising slightly so the economic uh
headwinds are extremely strong and
consumers are reacting to that in the
most logical way which is to hold back
the bit of evidence that there was some
forward shopping done in November so
some of the Christmas
um spending was done a little earlier as
consumers tried to spread the load of
Christmas of course the first Christmas
without any restrictions apart from
those that applied to people's wallets
retail sales falling back a blow to
Consumers and The Wider economy and a
sign that we are the bank of England
things probably at the start of a long
recession
okay yes I'm not terribly a positive
news there um Paul thanks very much
indeed
now Berlin is under mounting pressure to
allow its leopard tanks to be sent to
Ukraine as a meeting of Western allies
gets underway this morning at the
Ramstein Air Base in Southwestern
Germany Ukraine's President Vladimir
zielinski says he's expecting some
strong decisions from defense ministers
at that meeting
one of the most important elements of
Ukraine's Victory is tanks modern
Western tanks which we are negotiating
with our partners to supply and I thank
everyone who has already made the
appropriate decisions
the relevant Coalition of Partners has
already been formed and now we are
waiting for a decision from one European
Capital that will activate the prepared
chains of cooperation on tanks I believe
that the strength of German leadership
will remain unchanged
Alex Rossi joins us now from kramatosk
in eastern Ukraine's so Alex Germany
under a lot of pressure not just to send
tanks of its own but to allow other
countries to send those same tanks How
likely is it that it will approve the
move
well we'll have to wait and see what
happens in that meeting they are coming
under an enormous amount of
international pressure and the need for
those tanks here in front line towns and
cities in the donbass where the fighting
is most intense is extremely great now
military military experts were talking
before this war started about whether or
not the age of the tank really belonged
to a bygone era but here we have a
conflict which literally goes back to
the days of trench warfare now there are
two aspects of this for Ukraine as far
as it's concerned this holding the
status quo a stalemate which is
effectively kind of death to the country
by economic and destruction to its
infrastructure with the tax on its
cities there's also a massive Russian
mobilization coming hundreds of
thousands of men when winter is over all
of the military intelligence is
suggesting that so without these tanks
they they say they won't even be able to
hold the line but with the proper amount
amounts of Western support they can
actually go further than just holding
off the Russians they believe they can
win this conflict and take back the
territory which has been lost
Alex Rossi thanks very much indeed
now some breaking news for you this
morning a series of fresh strikes by
ambulance workers has been announced by
unite in an escalation of the dispute
over pay and Staffing at the union said
its members across England Wales and
Northern Ireland will stage 10 further
strikes over the coming weeks warning
that additional dates could be announced
soon so as you can see our political
correspondent Rappel has joined me
morning to you Rob so more strike dates
and a further headache for the
government yeah unite is one of several
unions that represents 999 staff and
ambulance workers that have been in this
protracted dispute overpay with the
government they this morning have
announced a number of new strike dates
for their members in England Wales and
Northern Ireland in England this will
affect the Northwest the Northeast the
East Midlands the West Midlands and then
of course Wales and Northern Ireland as
well the dates in various regions are
mainly the 6th and the 17th of February
and the 6th and 20th of March although
there is some minor variations in Wales
and Northern Ireland and also in some
regions in the north as well dependent
on on trusts this though aligns with
other strike dates that have been
announced the GMB Union which represents
ambulance workers as well is also
walking out on those dates and also the
Royal College of Nursing is walking out
on the 6th of February and the 7th of
February as well so the beginning of
February along with rail worker strikes
as well really beginning to look like a
focal point of industrial action I think
reading what United said this morning
it's interesting that this dispute
between the unions and the governments
over whether they had put cover in place
for the most urgent cases on ambulance
strike days that really looks to be
impacting how the unions are approaching
this they say they've been unfairly
accused of not putting cover in place
um so yes the material dispute is
overpay but it doesn't look like the
sort of mood music around the outside is
very good either okay interesting to
watch where that one goes so from
strikes to seat belts uh Rob uh Rishi
Cena got himself into a bit of bother
what's this all about yeah the Prime
Minister was in the northwest of England
yesterday promoting his leveling up fund
um he posted a picture on or a video on
Instagram to explain this initiative the
issue being as you can see there he
wasn't wearing a seat belt now they've
essentially coughed to this they've
admitted it they've said it was an error
of judgment that the Prime Minister
believes everyone should wear a seat
belt Lancashire police though he was in
Lancashire at the time we believe say
they're aware of this and they're
looking into the video
now I think the generous way to
interpret this I guess is it was a brief
lapse of judgment prime minister made a
mistake he's apologized he zoned up to
it and said that people should wear seat
belts at the same time though you can
get on the spot fines of 100 pounds for
not wearing seat belts it can increase
to 500 if it goes to court people will
wonder well if I got caught not wearing
a seatbelt would I get a fine
remember if she seemed like someone
that's had a penalty notice before for
breaches of covert rules when Boris
Johnson was prime minister and he was
Chancellor so it's the type of kind of
momentary lapse of judgment that when
your prime minister can seem kind of
innocuous and small but can lead you to
a bigger place as well given when you do
interviews with the Prime Minister and
with senior politicians usually staff
and officials are really really intense
and checking in what is in the
background that there's nothing
embarrassing that could get them into
trouble I think there's questions over
how this wasn't picked up by someone
around him as well because it's the type
of sort of off the cuff mistake that
when you're prime minister you really
can't afford to make yeah because it's a
film that he made himself wasn't it yeah
absolutely okay Rob the interesting to
see what that one goes as well thanks
very much indeed see you later
nothing coming up here on the show as
pressure mounts on Germany to send tanks
to support Ukraine ahead of that meeting
of Western allies today we'll be
speaking to the former deputy Supreme
Allied Commander of NATO General Sir
Richard Sheriff
also I'll speak to a former Metropolitan
Police assistant commissioner for
professionalism in the wake of the David
Carrick case
and also coming up I'm going to be
joined by Jeff Barton from the
association of school and college
leaders to discuss the teacher's strikes
going ahead in Scotland England and
Wales
in the meantime no lawyers for Alec
Baldwin say a decision to charge the
actor over a fatal movie Set shooting is
a terrible miscarriage of Justice
Baldwin is accused of involuntary
manslaughter over the death of the
cinematographer Helena Hutchins whose
family has welcomed the announcement
epistle was fired as Baldwin was
rehearsing with it on the set of his
Western film rust in October 2021.
well here's our U.S correspondent Martha
Kellner and a warning that her report
does contain some flash photography
I do have some very unfortunate news to
tell you what
um she didn't make it this is the moment
police officers told Alec Baldwin that
Helena Hutchins had died now
investigators have determined that he is
responsible and will charge the
Hollywood veteran with involuntary
manslaughter saying nobody is above the
law the gun was in his hand when he
pulled the trigger and that was the main
action that killed Helena Hutchins this
was something that was more than mere
negligence it was people acting
recklessly people not doing their jobs
people not following safety protocols
not following safety standards and
violating all of the standards that we
all have to follow if we have a gun in
our hands Helena Hutchins was 42 years
old a rising star behind the camera
she was recording a rehearsal inside
this church set in New Mexico when Alec
Baldwin shot her dead last I got from
her was it went in through her right and
out the left back okay he's always
denied pulling the trigger but
investigators have pieced together what
happened and say he did yes sir all
right
Baldwin has returned to normal life
since the shooting regularly appearing
on the red carpet with wife Hilaria in a
statement a lawyer for the actor said
this decision distorts Helena Hutchins
tragic death and represents a terrible
miscarriage of Justice Mr Baldwin had no
reason to believe there was a live
bullet in the gun or anywhere on the
movie Set he relied on the professionals
with whom he worked who assured him the
gun did not have live rounds we will
fight these charges and we will win
over the past year and a half I've
spoken to several people who worked on
the film rust some of whom raised
concerns about safety in the days before
Helena Hutchins was killed one described
guns lying around in the sand another
described what they called a willful
disregard for the welfare of caste and
crew one of her close friends telling me
this week he was praying for criminal
accountability for her death
what is your full name
[Music]
the alamara on the set Hannah Gutierrez
read was in charge of weapons despite
being just 24 years old at the time
she's also been charged with involuntary
manslaughter
assistant director Dave Halls here in
the blue shirt made a plea deal
admitting there was sufficient evidence
to convict him of negligent use of a
deadly weapon
Helena Hutchins left behind a
nine-year-old son her family welcomed
the charges prosecutors say if Baldwin
or others had done their job properly
she would still be here Martha Kellner
Sky News Los Angeles
well a U.S correspondent James Matthews
has the latest now from New York
there's been no sign of Alec Baldwin
here at his Manhattan apartment we have
seen his wife Hillary but she said
nothing the sentiments of the Baldwin
Camp are being articulated by his
lawyers they're calling this a terrible
miscarriage of Justice they say they
will fight it and will win no one's
disputing it was an accident that
occurred on this movie set in New Mexico
but prosecutors are saying that that
does not mean it wasn't a crime they
point to criminal negligence they say
that Alec Baldwin as an actor and as a
producer on that set should have been
aware of poor safety standards the actor
the Hollywood star is receiving support
from some quarters The Screen Actors
Guild in America has come to his defense
they're saying this in a statement they
say the prosecutor's contention that an
actor has a duty to ensure the
functional and mechanical operation of a
firearm on a production set is wrong and
uninformed they say an actor's job is
not to be a Firearms or weapons expert
so they're not happy Alec Baldwin is not
happy one party that is comforted in all
of this is we are told the family of the
woman who died on that movie said they
say without naming Alec Baldwin they're
comforted that nobody is above the law
they see anyone who does break the law
should be held accountable
let's take a look now are some of the
day's other headlines
and a home office report has found that
rape victims are having significant
amounts of their personal records
unnecessarily requested by police
causing delays in criminal
investigations in some cases records
were being requested to test the
credibility of victims in response the
home office is promising to better
protect victims from what it calls
invasive record requests
the climate activist Greta thundberg
appeared at the world economic Forum in
Davos on Thursday to deliver a cease and
desist notice to oil and gas companies
she said it was absurd that fossil fuel
CEOs are expected to find a solution to
the climate climate crisis given that
they are the problem
the family of a six-year-old boy who
shot and wounded his teacher in Virginia
says the gun he used had been secured in
a statement the family who haven't been
identified police said our heart goes
out to our son's teacher and we pray for
her healing and the aftermath of such an
unimaginable tragedy as she selfishly
served our son and the children in the
school our son suffers from an acute
disability and was under a care plan at
the school that included his mother or
father attending school with him and
accompanying him to class every day
Abigail's Werner who suffered injuries
that were initially considered
life-threatening has now been released
from hospital
political unrest and protests continue
in Peru's Capital where police have
fired tear gas in an attempt to control
the thousands who've poured into the
city to a protest against President Dina
boluarte the removal of her predecessor
president Pedro Castillo last month
launched deadly unrest
now the Church of England is expected to
issue an apology later this morning for
its historical attitude to lgbtq plus
people well joining me now to tell us
more is our correspondent shiman Freeman
Powell so shiman tell us a little bit
more about what we're expecting later on
this morning then
well we're expecting for there to be a
statement issuing an apology to lgbtq
plus communities for rejection exclusion
and hostility facing the past and the
impact it's had on lives that the Church
of England were also the Urgent for its
congregations to Welcome All same-sex
couples unreservedly and joyfully and it
comes as there's also an announcement
this week that for the first time
same-sex couples will be able to have
their blessings we'll be able to have
their civil Partnerships and civil
marriages blessed in the Church of
England and same same sex couples will
be able to give thanks for their civil
Partnerships now this comes after years
of debates about attitudes towards LGBT
plus communities and there's been lots
of contentious issues because safe set's
marriage was legalized in England the
world back in 2013 but the Church of
England have refused to change its
teaching so this Silverton really
changes teachings it just means that now
same-sex couples will be able to have
their their Partnerships blessed in the
church now the archbit bishop of
Canterbury Justin Welby has acknowledged
that he is under No Illusion that what
they are proposing will appear to go too
far for some and not nearly far enough
for others but we will have more details
about this apology later this morning
okay Simone I will be back to you a
little bit later thanks very much indeed
for now
so let's return down to the war in
Ukraine and the mounting pressure on
Germany to allow tanks to be sent to
Ukraine ahead of a meeting of Western
allies at the Ramstein Air Base in the
southwest of the country well I'm joined
now by the former deputy Supreme Allied
Commander of NATO generals Richard
Sheriff um thanks very much indeed for
joining us this morning we do appreciate
it first of all Britain has committed to
sending 14 Challenger 2 tanks to Ukraine
in your view should Germany follow suit
with its leopard tanks
without question
um absolutely I'm jumping you to hide
behind uh its principal Ally the United
States it has to step up up to the mark
and and lift the restrictions not not
only for itself but of course it also is
stunning the efforts of countries like
Finland and Poland who are very keen to
send their own leopard to tax but need
permission from Berlin to do so so yes
absolutely Germany must get on and do
this
and if Germany does commit to sending
its leopard tanks to Ukraine or at least
allow those third countries to supply
them how much of a game changer do you
think it would be
well it depends what on the numbers Anna
I mean it's a simple equation if
zelenski if president zielinski and the
Ukrainian senior staff senior generals
get the the full list of what they want
they will achieve pretty well all their
military objectives if you reduce the
numbers of uh of Tanks armored infantry
fighting Vehicles artillery air defense
etc etc uh so proportionately the gains
will will decrease so the more they can
send the better uh and and it's in
everybody's interest that that they do
so because this is what is going to
result in Ukraine achieving its military
objectives
there have been some concerns expressed
in Germany about escalation and how
President Putin might react to the
supply of these offensive weapons are
those worries justified in your view
no they're not I can't understand what
Germany is is is is is is is is worried
about here if anybody has escalated it
is it has been Putin uh who has who's
brought this uh appalling war on on a
democratic peaceful country the only way
to uh stop this is to defend Ukraine and
to give Ukraine the means to expel every
single last Russian from uh Ukrainian
territory uh so absolutely not Germany
must uh must must must
demonstrate strength and not weakness
because the Russians will only respect
strength at the moment the Germans are
demonstrating frankly a a a an
unacceptable weakness
some reports have suggested that
Chancellor Schultz will only give the
green light to these leopard tangs if
President Biden agrees to supply
American tanks to which would suggest
that he wants to coordinate with with
allies and not act alone should the U.S
Step Up
well it's difficult to see how the us
could step up I mean the U.S have
provided the vast majority of military
aid to Ukraine now this is Germany
hiding behind Americans skirt uh sort of
Apron Strings I'm afraid Germany's got
to realize that it is a presidential
Schultz leads an independent sovereign
country and they must make their own
decisions so they cannot afford it
cannot continue to hide behind the
Americans
the U.S does have its own Abraham tank
so doesn't it
it does absolutely and they're highly
capable but they are
um humongously complicated logistically
they they guzzle enormous amounts of
fuel uh and leopard two is a much more
appropriate tank for the Ukrainian needs
and of course it's also held by many
European countries so it would be much
easier to get leopard to there more
quickly
as we've said before Britain is
committing to sending 14 Challenger to
tanks Ben Wallace the defense secretary
has also announced that Britain will be
sending 600 Brimstone missiles in your
view is Britain doing enough
I would like to see as a former tank cat
tank commander I would like to see many
more than 14 tanks going but I'm afraid
this demonstrates the extent to which
defense Cuts in the last 20 years have
cut British defense capability not to
the Bone beyond the bone so 14 tanks 14
Challenger 2 is a capable oh that's an
impressive it's a number it's a good
number but but it's nothing like enough
I'd like to see
um I'd like to see 200 Challenger 2
tanks going to uh going to Ukraine uh
but the British simply don't have the uh
have they have have the resources
anymore
General Sir Richard Sheriff we
appreciate your time thanks very much
indeed for joining us and giving us your
views on this we we do appreciate it
following the shocking Revelation that
serial rapist PC David Carrick got away
with his crimes for years despite
opportunities to stop him more police
officers are facing allegations our home
editor Jason Farrell has spoken to two
women whose identities were protecting
and sent this report
across the country a growing number of
women have told Sky News they've lost
faith in the police following their own
experiences
if it happened to me again I wouldn't
report it nobody's going to believe me
and if I do say something what's gonna
happen to my family one of the police
officers turned out at the moment you've
got a very active imagination for every
girl aren't you
Amy not her real name reported an
alleged rape and says the male police
officer investigating began to make
sexual advances towards her he suggested
he come to see her at night with a
bottle of gin even when she was living
in a women's Refuge
I was on edge yard to think what if he
does turn up like what do I if he turns
up to a half to have sex with him is he
going to make him have sex with him if
if I don't have sex with him is my case
going to get close because of it
um to me it felt like he had a lot of
power
Amy Says The Unwanted advances continued
for a year after the trial and he also
made them to a female witness eventually
police turned up at Amy's door telling
her this man was being investigated for
things he'd done to other women but the
damage was done
it's like a huge abuse of power you just
don't trust the police anymore when
Charlotte reported her ex-partner for
alleged rape he was working for
Professional Standards which
investigates abusers in the police she
still serves in the force and says he
got the job despite a string of
complaints against him
I think to be fair the whole force was
shocked that he had a job in the
Professional Standards Department
because it was common knowledge that
he'd been investigated so many times
that's what he was known for
the force which we can't name says he
was later dismissed for gross misconduct
but despite previous allegations from
other women the crown prosecution
service in a letter to Charlotte gave
various reasons for not Prosecuting him
such as you were laughing as you told
the suspect to stop you could have
pushed him away and again he might not
have heard you say no
he might have interpreted ow in a
different way he might have believed you
too were aroused by The Hitting and it
concludes to my mind you had the freedom
to make a choice which included
reluctantly consenting it's just left me
feeling like I've been raped again but
by the justice system the people are
supposed to be looking after us
Charlotte believes predatory police
officers gain confidence in the
knowledge that so few rape cases reach
Court the stigma of speaking out also
helps abusers but after seeing how
serial rapist David Carrick escaped
detection for so long more women are
deciding to break their silence Jason
Farrell Sky News
when I buy the former Metropolitan
Police assistant commissioner for
professionalism Helen King who's now the
principal of Saint Anne's College in
Oxford uh Helen King a very good morning
to you
um I want to get your views on the
police after an extraordinary week but
first your thoughts on these latest
allegations reported there by my
colleague a woman for example saying she
came forward to report a rape and then
was subjected to a sexual advance from
the police officer investigating what
are your thoughts
of course each of those cases are
absolutely shocking
um I should be clear that
a very small proportion of police
officers
um have behaved like this
for
um all through my service and I think
the police have been investigating and
have been sacking some of them but
clearly not enough of them uh not
quickly enough we know the criminal
justice system isn't set up well to deal
with allegations of sexual assault I'm
horrified by the latest extreme cases
David Carrick when cousins of course but
the the glimmer of hope I have in it
that more women will come forward that
the police will dedicate more resources
um more effort into these really
difficult investigations because it is
in everyone's interest for these people
to be rooted out of the police
um and we need politicians and lawmakers
need to look at ways of making that more
straightforward and able to do it do it
quicker so although it's awful to hear
these stories some of them do sound
familiar to cases that I dealt with when
I was a serving police officer where we
did investigate people and and got
people sacked and the the drive and
focus on that absolutely needs to be
there but it will take resources and it
will take effort and there are things
that lawmakers and politicians can do to
assist the police in this
well yes and I'll come on to that in a
moment but I'm curious to know what your
own experience was when you were in the
Met police you spent many years there of
course did you witness did you
experience misogyny while you were there
well actually most of my service was in
two other police forces at Sony uh the
last three years of my 30 years as a
police officer that I was in the met and
you will see some of this contact
conduct in forces across the country and
Professional Standards departments
absolutely should be focused and
responding to it so I can remember cases
of rape that um that I investigated
committed by police officers going way
back to the beginning of this Century
where through real efforts through use
of intrusive Powers by being absolutely
focused on getting these people out of
the job and before the courts we were
successful but it does take effort and
it is really difficult for women to come
forward we shouldn't underestimate that
and recognize I think one of the women
you spoke to there was already in a
women's Refuge was already clearly in a
vulnerable position and these these
offenses this conduct by people who are
police officers is repugnant it's
repugnant to the public and it's even
more repugnant in a sense to the many
tens of thousands of police officers who
are trying to do a good job who are
trying to protect the vulnerable and to
increase the Public's confidence and
trust and policing
do you think that the Met police is
institutionally misogynistic
I think Society still has elements of
misogyny and we see that in policing and
in other public and private
organizations
um and there is something about the
powers that are given to a police
officer over their fellow citizens that
they have to have in order to do their
job and should be used in the interests
of of us all that can attract people
um who who want that power for the wrong
reasons and that's why it's so important
that really good people are still
attracted to policing can see that it's
a really worthwhile and satisfying job
as well as one that is extremely
challenging and demanding and so I think
we all need to make sure that we think
about policing we encourage the right
kind of people into it and we support
the many tens of thousands of police
officers who desperately want to do a
good job on behalf of us all
you said that the government needs to be
able to act to make it easier for for
the police to clean up their act
um the Home Secretary would say that
they are making it quicker and easier to
sack officers involved in wrongdoing
they're going to take steps to do that
what would you like to see the
government do
I think that's right to look at police
regulations again but I think
politicians also need to think very hard
about the crude targets that they
sometimes try to impose on the police
whether that's trying to recruit large
numbers of officers at a very quick Pace
whether it's about
um not being realistic about how the
police have to spread their resources
and how do you prioritize between the
many priority demands on policing so
make sure that they have the resources
that they need to do the job and and
think very hard about the kind of
sometimes crude headline grabbing
targets that they give the police that
can skew the BET their
um their thinking and their focus from
the things that actually really are the
most important
now the department for Education will
meet with all four teaching unions today
after the UK's largest education Union
announced seven days of strikes in
February and March well I'm joined Now
by Jeff Barton who's General Secretary
of the association of school and college
leaders a very good morning to you Jeff
Barton I know that you met with the
education secretary earlier this week
along with other teachers unions first
of all tell us how that went
well I think first of all Anna I would
say it's good that she met us it's the
second meeting with her with these
schools minister with senior officials I
think you know I'm a veteran English
teacher so inevitably what I would just
say is we met with the Secretary of
State for education in England this week
we also yesterday met with the cabinet
secretary for education in Wales and as
an English teacher I do a kind of
compare and contrast because I think
what we got with the education secretary
or someone who I think tribally sees
unions as part of the problem
and was reluctant to talk about what we
think is the key issue which is pay how
do you recruit great graduates to choose
this profession and what we saw I think
in Wales with the cabinet secretary was
somebody who opened by saying this is
the beginning of a negotiation around
pay it was much more direct because of
the social partnership between the
government there and where's but I'll go
back to my opening point it's good that
a we've had a couple of those meetings
with the secretary of state and
ministers it's good in one sense that
we've got six hours of talks that's a
long time I have to say six hours of
talks where pay is the number one issue
on the agenda that feels to me like it
is a step forward
uh more meetings happening today
um at the department for education I
think you're not attending as far as I
understand but what are your
expectations then for today
oh I'll I'll be there Anna it's really
really important I thought you weren't
going but yeah go ahead how do you think
it's going to go that's a rumor put
around by my arrivals I I think we're
looking at the agenda where I think
there's been a a bit of a frustration if
I'm honest that it feels like if you're
the Secretary of State for Education
you're not supposed to talk about
negotiation because you're putting all
your faith in the independent review
bodies and we've had endless ministers
haven't we wheeled out on Sky News
talking about the independence of those
review bodies we support the principal
we question a little bit whether
Independence is independent but you can
see how that means that for Secretary of
State it's difficult for her to talk
about I am negotiating if that in her
world undermines the work of the
independent review body and the only
thing I would say is the reason that
some teachers are talking about
industrial action is not because of what
an independent pay review body may
choose to do around pay next year it's
because of the way they're being paid
now and from my point of view school and
college leaders it's how do we get the
best graduates to choose a profession
where some of the things you won't get
in other professions like working from
home flexible working in the way that
you would do an office all of that page
suddenly becomes more important if we
want great graduates to be there on
behalf of parents who would expect as a
qualified teacher teaching their child
across a range of subjects that is the
heart of this issue and six hours of
talks will feel probably a long time I'm
pleased to be in the room I'm pleased
we're talking about pay and then moving
on to conditions of service and where
does your union stand on strikes I
understand that your members haven't
been balloted for strike action what
would it take for that to happen
but we're in a position that we did
um pretty unexpectedly and certainly for
the first time ever an unprecedented
consultative ballot and that meant we
were saying to members we know you're
you're feeling angry about things tell
us what that is and there's a range of
things that people I represent the
Guardians of the nation's young people
as Leaders of schools and colleges
funding is one of those the inability to
be able to recruit teachers and support
staff is a second one and the fact that
the job they came into the moral
imperative of giving opportunities to
children and young people frankly for
almost a decade in many cases they've
been doing the opposite and they've been
cutting courses increasing class sizes
and having to make staff redundance
they're really cross about that but in
particular we want to see teaching
become a more high profile High status
profession pay and conditions are parts
of that I'm hoping that what we get from
today is a sense of talking about those
real and genuine issues rather than
skirting around them and not thinking
that this is purely a postcode thing
this has been a decade in the making the
the government has missed its
recruitment targets today
of the children being taught maths there
will be something like uh 20 of those
lessons not being taught by qualified
maths teachers now I think if we're
going to talk about minimum service
level agreements on behalf of the
nation's parents the government should
be committing to a qualified teacher for
every teacher in every classroom that's
what these talks are about
okay and Jillian Keegan the education
secretary was on this program early in
the week and she told my colleague Kay
Burley that she was very disappointed
that teachers were going on strike she
said our children don't deserve it do
you have sympathy with your fellow
teaching Union the Neu that has voted to
strike or do you understand where the
education secretary is coming from
oh I think I think if you talked to the
teachers who are talking about
industrial action they would probably
say the same as Julian Keegan the
Secretary of State we are very
disappointed they would say that we are
having to resort to going on strike we
didn't come into the job for that
striking isn't an end game in all of
this and from from my point of view
having done a consultative ballot it's
giving us the space to be able to say
look the people I represent school and
college leaders they are feeling so
crossed that they're putting pressure on
me that we ought to move to a ballot
this really tells you something
secretary of state so let's let's get
away from the politicking and the the
potential denigration we see in some
parts of the press of the teaching
profession teachers want to be in the
classroom but they also want to see
great graduates choose the profession in
the future because frankly our children
deserve better than they have been
getting for almost a decade
do you worry that children are going to
be the real losers here after the years
of disrupted education because of the
pandemic
of course and no one wants that and
certainly the members that I've got are
spending their time thinking how do we
make sure that in particular if we can
those most vulnerable children will on
those days where there is some strike
action uh get the best possible
education that we are able to provide on
the other hand we do have to be
realistic about this the percentage of
teachers who are teaching in their
subject area is getting worse and worse
every year 400 schools according to the
Institute of physics will be teaching
a-level physics today without a
qualified physics teacher I think that's
a big unknown story and if essentially
what it means is industrial action is
going to start to put education up the
political agenda as we move towards an
election well that is something I think
parents would say if you're not fighting
for it in the profession frankly who is
because it doesn't feel that the
government is
okay Jeff Boston that thanks so much for
your time and uh do give us some
feedback on that meeting that you are
attending later on today thanks very
much indeed
now the American singer and guitarist
David Crosby has died at the age of 81.
[Music]
[Music]
Crosby was one of the most influential
rock singers of the 60s and 70s and
we'll have more tributes to him in the
next hour as well as Labor's Nick Thomas
Simmons stay with us
[Applause]